we've reported on the so-called american
rescue plan and how it's really a blue
state bailout but it's even worse than
that there are strings attached to the
over
300 billion dollars given to states and
localities one of them is
no new tax cuts it actually stops
states from doing tax cuts here to
discuss all of that and more tennessee
senator
marsha blackburn let's get to violence
biden's bailout
in a second but i just love your
reaction to the news we reported
at the top of the show president biden
finally
saying something about andrew cuomo
totally inadequate as we discussed
earlier
what's your take on where the cuomo
scandal stands tonight
i tell you i think you're exactly right
it is inadequate and there are growing
calls
by a bipartisan group of legislators
at the local state and federal level who
are calling for him
to resign and probably he should be
listening more
to the people that are there in albany
and spending less
time trying to plead his case across the
country
yeah i think a lot of people will agree
with that and not just
republicans that's what's interesting
about this the the way democrats
are finally weighing in but still
nothing from vice president harris as i
noted earlier the
great champion of the metoo movement
you'll remember that from those hearings
uh senator let's talk about the um the
bailout bill it seems to me that this
particular
aspect of it the requirement that if if
states take the any of the bailout money
then they are forbidden or can be
stopped by the treasury secretary from
implementing tax cuts in their states
that is a blatant federal
power grab that's like very blatant but
it seems to be the whole thing
is a federal power grab yes
you're exactly right it is a federal
power grab and steve what they're trying
to do
is go for control and power
over all the states and the cities
they're trying to force their will
and centralize federal government so
this is the way they're going about it
and if you take the money
then you cannot cut taxes now the reason
they're doing this i think
is because you have several state
legislatures this year
that are trying to do what tennessee did
probably 20 years ago which is to make
certain that we never have a state
income tax
and even putting it in our state
constitution
in 2014 in the form of an amendment
but see the federal government wants to
tax you
so that they have more to spend so if
they're going to give money to
your local governments they want you to
be beholden
to the federal government so it doesn't
matter if it is
telling you how you can tax when you can
tax
it doesn't matter if it's telling you
how you're going to run
elections doesn't matter if it's about
gun
rights what they're trying to do is take
control and micromanage
every city every county and every state
in this country
it's really interesting as i hear you
talk it reminds me actually of the eu
they had this this policy of stopping
tax competition as they called it which
is really about stopping countries like
the uk
from cutting taxes to make themselves
more competitive very quickly senator is
there anything we can do it seems to be
there's so much of this is
unconstitutional can we fight that case
legally
you're going to see some of the states
that will take this to court
as well as they should and then
legislatively you'll see us
begin to go back in and file legislation
to pair some of these provisions
that were stuck into this bill
in order to give the democrats control
what they want to do is to dominate to
make it impossible
for there to be a two-party system they
want to run the whole show and they're
using
this hr1 and other pieces of legislation
such as defund the police in order to
centralize their power and control
exactly senator great to see you as
always good to see you
see you soon